RIGHT?
WHEN THEY SHOW YOU, AREN’T YOU
SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE THEM?
LET’S GO TO THIS FROM WHAT THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK JUST SAID.
IF YOU’RE HAVING A PROBLEM WITH
THIS DECISION THAT WAS MADE, IF
YOU’RE HAVING A PROBLEM WITH THE
DEATHS OF THESE SENIORS ON THE
REPORT FROM THE AG OFFICE
SHOWING THAT THERE WERE SO MANY
MORE OF THEM, LET’S HEAR FROM
THE GOVERNOR.
>> IF YOU THINK THERE WAS A
MISTAKE, TALK TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
IT’S NOT ABOUT POINTING FINGERS
OR BLAME.
IS THAT THIS BECAME A POLITICAL
FOOTBALL, RIGHT?
WHETHER A PERSON DIED IN THE
HOSPITAL FOR DIED IN THE NURSING
HOME, PEOPLE DIED.
PEOPLE DIED.
>> Harris: IT’S SHOCKING.
IF IT’S SHOCKING.
NO MATTER WHERE YOU DIED, PEOPLE
DIED, BUT HE MADE THE DECISION
TO PUT THOSE PEOPLE WHO WERE
INFECTED WITH THE LEAST AMONG US
WHO COULD FIGHT THINGS OFF.
THAT DOES MATTER.
>> Kim: I AGREE WITH DAVE,
THAT WAS AN EMBARRASSING PRESS
BRIEFING.
HE BASICALLY PASS THE BUCK
ALONG, SAID HE HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH WHAT HAPPENED, BUT I
REMEMBER VIVIDLY WHEN HE WAS
BLAMING PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR THE
ROLLOUT, BLAMING NURSING HOME
WORKERS FOR GOING INTO WORK AND
POSSIBLY HAVING COVID, BUT NOW
HE’S SAYING IT’S GOD AND SOME OF
IT COULD BE LIVE, MAYBE NOT COME
ON BABY DIDN’T KNOW IT WAS
ACCURATE BUT PEOPLE SHOULD DO A
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION INTO
EVERYTHING HE’S WORKING ON.
HE WROTE A BOOK LIKE THEY’VE
SAID AND DIDN’T EVEN HAVE THE
ACCURATE NUMBER AND THEN POSTED
THE NUMBER AND SAID
NEW YORK STATE HAS ONLY 28%
DEATHS IN NURSING HOMES BUT JUST
TOLD US RIGHT BEFORE THAT AND HE
DID NOT HAVE THE ACCURATE
NUMBER.
IF SO HE DOESN’T EVEN KNOW.
SO I HATE THE FACT THAT HE GAVE